this video is brought to you by
manscape.com keep yourself
well groomed with the performance kit
from manscape more on them in just a bit
when scholars rank u.s presidents there
are four 20th century names that always
break the top 10.
fdr truman teddy roosevelt and dwight d
eisenhower one of the most popular men
in this era eisenhower had the fortune
to lead america through a prolonged
economic boom
during his tenure the middle class
drastically expanded poverty was reduced
and
peace and stability reigned this was the
era of tv's first golden age of consumer
choice of exciting new technology when
films and shows like happy days and back
to the future wanted to portray american
innocence
it would be to eisenhower's era that
they returned again and again
yet who really was the man at the center
of it all who was the president
who steered the nation through one of
its most iconic decades
born in modest circumstances in north
texas eisenhower grew up fascinated with
the military
joining the army as a young man he rose
through the ranks eventually becoming
supreme commander
of allied forces during d-day swept to
the presidency on the back of his
wartime popularity
he promised an era of optimism his
successes and failures
would define an entire generation
you know how some kids know from the age
of like four exactly what they want to
do with their lives
well that was dwight eisenhower all over
from almost the moment he could read the
future president wanted to be in the
military born on october the 14th 1819 a
ramshackle house in denison north texas
there had been nothing in eisenhower's
background that indicated army material
his father was a blue collar worker
while his mother was a pacifist
man and i who considered war almost as
immoral as
laziness for young i because eisenhower
was known
that meant a boyhood of prayer and hard
work it also meant inheriting a
hilariously victorian attitude to
society even when he was president
ike would blush crimson if he ever
accidentally used cuss word in front of
a woman
yet behind this strict religious
upbringing behind this facade of a
blue-collar football-loving boy lurked
an ambition that would shape
the nation whenever he had a moment to
spare eisenhower devoured books about
military history although he kept it
quiet from his mom it's not too hard to
imagine he
already had his heart set on an army
career the first step in realizing this
dream came
in 1911. by now living with his folks in
kansas i could grown into an athletic
competitive man whose stern discipline
masked a volcanic temper
he was also a supremely hard worker
after graduating high school
bike made a pact with his brother edgar
to work for two years
to pay edgar's tuition fees afterwards
edgar would go out to work to support
eisenhower's studies
true to his word ike had taken two jobs
to keep edgar in education
barely giving himself enough time to
sleep but before edgar could fulfill his
side of the bargain
good news came eisenhower's way west
point military academy was going to
accept him
free of charge for most of the family
this is the first they learned of the
young man's military ambitions
it said that his pacifist mom burst into
tears but there was no talking the boy
out of it he enrolled at the academy and
promptly settled into being utterly
average yep that burning ambition of
eisenhower's hadn't extended to being a
great officer
or a great general he was content to
coast by to do the bare minimum required
to fill his dream of seeing action
we can see this from his ranking at
graduation 61st out of 164
solid but certainly not spectacular
still this was nearly enough
in spring of 1917 the usa declared war
on germany by now married to mammy
geneva dowd who
had met while stationed in san antonio
ike had every reason to hope america's
entry into world war one
would prove to be his shot at glory even
though he was forced to spend the year
in charge of a tank training center in
pennsylvania the army was soon
shipping people out by the thousands in
late 1918
ike finally got the call well before he
could set out for europe
history intervened in november 1918
world war one ended
eisenhower must have been the only
person on earth upset to see the carnage
over
grouching that had missed his big
opportunity he instead turned to working
with an army buddy named cameo alert
george s patton on a series of articles
advising the military to invest
in tanks for future conflicts but rather
than being like cool
consider us advised the army brass are
more like no pogcast president is going
to tell us what to do
indeed they threatened him with court
martial shunted off to the panama canal
zone told to keep his opinions to
himself
eisner could have faded into obscurity
then and there had it not been for one
man
down in panama ike's commanding officer
was general fox connor a guy who valued
creative thinking
when he heard the younger man's ideas
for the future of warfare connor didn't
threaten him with punishment
instead he pulled some strings and got
him into the prestigious command and
general staff college
this was where the future of the
military was made
a place for the creme de la creme of the
officer corps
connor was taking a huge gamble sending
an average soldier
like eisenhower there but it was a
gamble that would pay off
for the entire world now before we go
any further with
dwight's story let's have a quick word
from today's
video sponsor landscaped manscaped if
you aren't familiar is a company aimed
specifically at men who understand the
value of being well
groomed and you should understand their
value think of them as a
hardware store but for your body
manscaped has
this great performance package kit that
they've sent me it's not just this
this is of course this is the the
lawnmower 3.0 with skin safe technology
because
where this is designed to shave you want
that skin safe
technology trust me but it also comes
with all sorts of great stuff the crop
preserver
of course this is as it says right here
on this very nice text by the way it's
sort of
gold text on this matte black ground it
looks fantastic and in that gold text
and on that black ground it says
ball deodorant you know no joking around
about what this is
fantastic stuff also comes with this
this is a uh a nose trimmer i and an ear
trimmer
ear hair trimmer i don't have any ear
hair but i do get nose hair
and this thing's great i had a cheaper
one that i got from the drugstore before
which uh it feels about half as heavy as
this
and it's kind of a piece of crap this
feels
it's weighty it's good it sounds
fantastic you get one of these as well
and of course in this you get your nail
kit which is the clipper the uh
the tweezers the the scissors all of
that good stuff
and as if that wasn't enough manscapes
offering two complimentary gifts for a
limited time the
shed travel bag and a pair of their cool
anti-chafing boxer briefs
fantastic so if you want to start
looking good from head to toe with
no pair of stones left unturned you can
head to manscape.com to get 20
off plus free international shipping and
those two free gifts just use the promo
code bio20 again manscape.com promo code
bio20
or just follow the link in the
description below now let's get ready
for war
once eisenhower got into command and
general staff college he never looked
back
when he graduated in 1926 he was first
in his class of 245.
from there it was the army war college
then traveling with big shot generals to
get experience
but the biggest shockiest general of
them all was still to come in 1933
eisenhower became an aide for army chief
of staff
general douglas macarthur yeah that
douglas macarthur
fan of corncob pipes aviator sunglasses
and generally being an
all-round hard ass it was a prime
posting for a rising star like
eisenhower a chance to see the baddest
general of them all
up close and personal but god damn
it would be a bumpy ride like eisenhower
mccarthy had a foul temper and an
unwillingness to bag down
during the six or so years they worked
together mostly in the philippines
eisenhower would find himself
tearing what little remain of his hair
out trying to get macarthur to listen
still the experience taught him a lot
and sent him climbing ever further up
the ranks that meant that ike was in the
perfect place career-wise
when war broke out again in europe sent
back to the usa in 1940 eisnow was
promoted to chief of staff for the third
army just in time
for the legendary louisiana maneuvers by
1940 the american military was
modernizing like crazy in case war came
and everyone needed some practice to
figure out how to wield
this high-powered new fighting machine
so general george c
marshall basically had his men pick out
an empty patch of louisiana
and said well that'll do and sent nearly
half a
million troops down there to war game
the crap out of it did eisenhower
shine during the maneuvers yeah of
course he did
eisenhower's strategic planning in
louisiana was so impressive that he was
promoted
straight to brigadier general just in
time too because
that december world war ii finally
caught up with america the bombing of
pearl harbor
was the beginning of eisenhower's
stratospheric rise
through the ranks sent to dc to work on
war plans he caught the eye of general
marshall who promoted him
right the way up to commander of u.s
troops in europe partly this was due to
eisenhower's ability but it was also due
to him being the sort of person that
people trusted
remember that whole political slogan i
like ike well it worked because
liking ike was exactly what people did
despite his discipline and strict
religious background dwight eisenhower
was one of those guys you just can't
help but want to be around he was clever
funny plain spoken but also sharply
intelligent and persuasive
as the great british world war ii
officer berna montgomery put it he has
the power of drawing the hearts of men
toward him
as a magnet attracts the bit of metal he
merely
has to smile at you and you trust him at
once in other words eisenhower was
basically the military equivalent
of the brainy beautiful prom queen
everyone wants to be around
only instead of a homecoming parade he
got to invade north africa
launched in november 1942 operation
torch saw the allies overrun vichy
france's colonies triggering a
revolution in algeria
and helping to bring the north africa
campaign crashing to a close
although eisenhower's planning wasn't
perfect mistakes were made including the
assumption that french colonial forces
would
welcome them as liberators he did the
job with north africa secured eisenhower
was able
to pivot to overseeing the invasion of
sicily the campaign that led to
mussolini
being removed from power as italy
collapsed into two warring states one
aligned with the allies the other with
the axis
it became clear that the wind was
changing direction that the
much-promised invasion
of france might now even be possible
can't you guess who'd be leading it
in later life when he was president
dwight eisenhower was asked brian's
brother milton to read the commencement
address
a penn state the morning of the big
speech big storms blew up threatening
the ceremony
panicked milton asked his brother for
advice if the weather turned in response
ike merely smiled and said milton i
haven't worried about the weather since
june 6
1944. that's because june 6 was the day
eisenhower had overseen the greatest
seabourn invasion
in history d-day promoted to supreme
commander of the allied expeditionary
force on christmas eve 1943
eisenhower had spent the previous six
months liaising in london with winston
churchill
and charles de gaulle to make sure that
things went right there were a lot of
ways they could have gone wrong
because of the tidal requirements and
the need for a full moon there were only
a few days of any given month when the
landings could be pulled off
that meant bad weather could throw not
just eisenhower's plans but
the fate of the whole of europe into
disarray originally i could schedule
d-day for june
5th only to abort when bad weather was
predicted so it was with a feeling of
incredible tenseness that
eisenhower listened to the forecast for
june the 6th this was it
the last day that month when conditions
would be perfect even if they did the
landings when the tides were right again
in two weeks
there'd be no full moon quietly
eisenhower heard the meteorologist
predictions for the morning
probably fine with an outside chance of
storms and he
said the three words that changed the
course of the war
okay let's go that morning of june 6
eisenhower spoke to the assembled men
you are about to embark upon the great
crusade the boy from north texas told
them
toward which we have striven these many
months the eyes of the world
are upon you with those words d-day
began
the landings at normandy are the stuff
of legend and could easily occupy an
entire
30-minute or more video of their own
some 156
000 troops stormed the beaches backed up
by an invasion force numbering
1 million on june the 6th alone nearly 4
500 allied soldiers were killed with
another 6 000 plus wounded or missing
in the coming weeks thousands upon
thousands more would die
but it was also the beginning of the end
for the third reich
that december with paris liberated eyes
now was made a five-star general just
months later nazi germany surrendered
ending the war in europe and ike would
return home a hero yet his reputation
wasn't entirely spotless
in the last days of the european
conflict eisenhower pulled his men back
allowing the soviets to capture berlin
this was what had been agreed at yalta
regardless people back home accused the
general of handing the communists a
propaganda victory but while the
criticism may have stung
it didn't derail ike's career in the
slightest that november with the war in
the pacific also over
harry truman promoted eisenhower to
chief of staff ike had his disagreements
with the president he thought truman had
been a fool to authorize the use of atom
bombs against japan
arguing it made america look bad but the
two still got on well enough
so well that after eisenhower stepped
back from duty in early 1948 truman
suggested they should run on a joint
ticket in that year's election
and it wasn't just truman despite never
having voted himself eisenhower was now
being courted by factions in both
parties to run for president
it was clear the public thought he was a
shoo-in to win
and he would be just not yet ike turned
all election offers down saying he
needed to focus on serving his country
that november truman won a shock second
term in the aftermath the president
promoted eisenhower to supreme commander
of nato forces but 1948's brief brush
with politics
wouldn't be ike's last in just four
short years the general
would return to washington and this time
it would be as commander-in-chief
[Music]
harry truman's presidency officially
ended on the 20th of january 1953 but
really it had come crashing to an end
over two years earlier in the summer of
1950. that's because
that was the summer the korean war broke
out the korean war was as much a kick in
the nuts to truman's presidency as
vietnam was to lyndon johnson's or the
iraq war was to george w bush's
the nadir came when truman relieved
douglas macarthur of his commands thus
tanking his own popularity back home
although truman had now served two terms
the 22nd amendment had made an exception
for him as the sitting president
when it came into force in 1951. legally
he could have run again
but career put paid to that with no
possibility of winning his party's
nomination
harry truman agreed to step aside he
hoped to create some space for a new
generation of democrat to take the white
house
instead he threw the door wide open for
an eisenhower landslide
all through truman's second term ike had
been saying that he wouldn't run with
all the sincerity of someone who is just
desperate to be president when a group
of internationalist republicans
approached him worried that their party
might nominate an isolationist the nato
commander sensed an opening in january
1952 eisenhower announced that he would
seek the presidency
as a republican despite his massive
popularity with the public
getting on a ticket was far from a sure
thing primaries were different beasts in
the mid-20th century with many delegates
chosen by the party as a result
eisenhower went into the 1952 convention
unsure if the nomination would go to him
or the isolationist and
son of former president robert a taft
it's at this point that a certain
californian senator
enters our story at the convention
richard nixon was eisenhower's greatest
asset
swinging enough delegates behind ike to
take him over the top
in fact ike was so certain that dick
nixon had secured him the nomination
that he made the senator his running
mate so yeah you could totally blame one
of america's best 20th century president
for paving the way for one of its
absolute worst the campaign that fall
was a watershed for us politics 1952 is
considered the first time tb played a
significant role in an election with the
i like ike jingle becoming a national
catchphrase
although a pissed off harry truman tried
to sink eisenhower's campaign by telling
people there was a time when i thought
he would make a good president that was
my mistake there was no doubt he was
going to win
especially after eisenhower made i will
go to korea
one of his campaign pledges that
november i can dick one electoral
college landslide one which netted the
gop both chambers of congress for
only the second time since herbert
hoover's presidency on january 20th 1953
dwight diaz now became the 34th
president
one of his first acts was to follow
through on his career promise by now the
korean war had been raging for nearly
three years with tens of thousands of
american deaths and
millions of dead civilians howardly
eisenhower struck the posture of a
peacemaker but
behind the scenes he tried to drop hints
that the u.s would consider a nuclear
attack on north korea's back at china
if peace wasn't forged today it's
thought unlikely that the threat
ended the war with the change in
leadership in the ussr likely playing a
larger role but when an armistice
was signed in july of 1953 it was atomic
weapons that eisner thought
had given him the edge for the rest of
his tenure eisenhower's official policy
would be nuclear attacks on any
communist nation
that threatened america's allies a
policy that became known
as massive retaliation as we'll soon see
though the reality of the cold war would
be far more complex than
ike's policy allowed
[Music]
despite the constant threat of nuclear
annihilation the culture at large
remembers the 50s as a great time to be
an american mainly
thanks to a shared economic boom
although a fiscal conservative by nature
eisenhower was smart enough to know how
popular fdr's new deal policies remained
with the public
while his administration would take an
axe to some like ending price and rent
controls
others he left intact or even expanded
under eisenhower social security was
increased the minimum wage went up
low-cost housing was built and
massive public works undertaken the
biggest of these was undoubtedly the
interstate highway program which
provided employment
for swaths of people at the same time
the president refused to lower taxes
saying it would be a waste of time
as a result his bitterest opposition in
congress wasn't from democrats who
retook the house and sent it in 1954 but
the right wing
of his own party still eisenhower's
modern republicanism worked
across his two terms unemployment mostly
stayed low inflation hovered at two
percent and families found themselves
able to buy things like second cars or
newfangled tv sets while around a fifth
of americans still lived in poverty it
was a number that fell
across ike's eight years in short it was
a great time to be alive with
one important caveat to get the most out
of the eisenhower years
he had to be white although we remember
the 1960s as the civil rights era it was
very much
a live issue in eisenhower's time the
military was desegregating the
montgomery bus boycott was about to kick
off a charismatic preacher named martin
luther king jr was making waves and
attitudes were changing among those
changing were the attitudes of
eisenhower himself
rather than pretend like everything was
hunky-dory ike was aware that his
america
was an unequal one and he was deeply
conflicted about it
on the one hand he seems to have felt
that his administration could
and should improve the lives of
non-white americans on the other hand he
also had a huge sympathy for
racist whites afraid of equality you can
see this internal conflict play out time
and time again
in the eisenhower era on the positive
side you have the civil rights act of
1957.
championed by eisenhower it was the
first piece of civil rights legislation
passed since reconstruction
giving federal protection to voting
rights it should have been a game
changer for southern blacks who were
often disenfranchised by
dull ass tests or taxes but note the
operative words in that sentence
should have while eisenhower had the
best intentions his legislation
was just too toothless for example it
gave disenfranchised voters the right to
appeal before a jury
but in the jim crow south where juries
were all white
this just didn't make a damn difference
on the negative side you all said the
hot mess that was brown and bored of
education
in 1954 the supreme court desegregated
in this landmark ruling as he usually
did eisenhower refrain from commenting
but this time
his lack of comment was taken as a tacit
nod by racist southerners
in 1957 the governor of arkansas felt
empowered to use the national guard to
block nine black students from enrolling
at central high school in little rock
eisenhower tried to talk him down and
then sent federal troops to enforce
desegregation yet he still
never spoke up for the principles of
integrated education
never had a moment like jfk's famous
address arguing that desegregation
wasn't just the law but a moral
imperative
in the end it would be lyndon johnson
who took the mantle of civil rights
president
but that crown could have been
eisenhower's had he pushed just a little
harder
he could have transformed the lives of
millions of black americans and in doing
so
transformed himself from merely a good
president into a truly great
one
as the 1956 election approached it
wasn't at all certain eisenhower would
run again
for years he had been telling friends
it'd be content to be a one-term wonder
then in 1955 he was knocked flat
by a massive heart attack many wondered
if it ever recover yet recover
ike did he recovered and he ran again
for the presidency
it was an even more lopsided win than in
1952. eisenhower crushed
it at the polls sweeping even southern
states that hadn't voted republican
since reconstruction yet while ike was
always going to win
the margins were only so favorable
because of what was happening in the
rest of the world
just a few days before the election
france britain and israel had secretly
teamed up to launch a surprise attack on
egypt the suez crisis
was the result of egypt's leader
nationalizing the suez canal
but that's not important for this video
what is important is that none of the
three attacking forces bothered to tell
the us what they were going to do
and when eisenhower found out he was
pissed if britain and france
still had any illusions about who was
the superpower they lost them when
eisenhower did the geopolitical
equivalent of
spanking their asses holding back their
allowance and grounding them for all
eternity
while the crisis was a humiliation for
the europeans it made eisenhower look
every bit the badass general
like it been back in world war ii but
while the suez crisis saw ike act
decisively
his foreign policy wouldn't always be so
resolute in fact it would be
more often characterized by surprising
hesitancy
the same year as the suez crisis an
anti-communist revolution blew up in
hungary one
swiftly followed by a soviet invasion
given his policy of massive retaliation
some expected eisenhower to respond to
soviet aggression
but despite or perhaps because of his
years as war hero eisenhower just didn't
want to get involved he didn't want to
risk another war
something similar played out in the war
in indochina in 1954 the french
requested american assistance to subdue
their former colonies
as he would with hungary though
eisenhower demured the french were
defeated
and cambodia vietnam and lao became
independent nations
unlike the general eisenhower who'd
stormed the beaches of normandy
president eisenhower seemed to avoid a
fight at any cost
at least he did openly behind the scenes
he authorized the cia to do some
seriously dirty stuff it was under
eisenhower that the cia of infamy the
coup plotting government toppling cia
came into its own
with eisenhower's knowledge the agency
deposed elected leaders in iran and
guatemala
helping set up two dictators and trigger
a civil war
while the other presidents would
authorize more destructive actions it
was eisenhower who
first really let the cia loose yet what
did his voters care
the odd suez crisis aside foreign
affairs just didn't figure that much
into americans minds
especially when things were not going so
well at home deizernaw's presidency
finally ended in january 1961. by then
he'd overseen the last expansion of the
union when hawaii and alaska both became
states in 1959.
although it was broadly popular when he
stepped down there were still signs
that the era of i like ike was coming to
an end the previous november voters had
plumped not for the continuity candidate
richard nixon
but a young senator from massachusetts
who promised a new direction
but while ike would live to see the
whole of the jfk lbj
era he wouldn't be around much longer in
1965 eisenhower suffered another heart
attack that left him badly weakened
three years later
he had sickened enough to be permanently
checked into walter reed army hospital
he'd never leave on march 28 1969
dwight eisenhower died aged 78. he'd
lived just long enough to see his
grandson marry the daughter of his old
vp julie nixon setting up a new
political dynasty
now he was content to spend his final
moments holding his beloved mammy's hand
his last words were i want to go god
take me
the america ike left behind was already
very different from the one he'd ruled
civil rights had drastically expanded
the country was embroiled in a
devastating war in vietnam
and new social movements had exploded
that would have been unthinkable just a
decade earlier
and yet it would be this new america
that came to recognize ike
as one of its best modern leaders today
with the benefit of hindsight we can see
that eisenhower wasn't quite a great
president even if he was a very good one
he could
and should have pushed harder on civil
rights and his willingness to interfere
in countries like iran and guatemala
left some hot messes behind that his
successors would have to clear up
still when you get down to it there's no
doubting that eisenhower was a
fundamentally decent man
who enjoyed a remarkable career i mean
even if it never become president it'd
probably still feature him in a video
as the guy who led goddamn d-day that he
managed to not just go on to become
president
but also be one of the top 10 presidents
of all time
speaks volumes about his abilities as a
leader and perhaps that's how he'd want
to be remembered not just as a president
but as a leader
a man who led his country through one of
the defining decades of its existence
whether you think he was a truly great
president or merely a good one
there's no doubting that without him
both the u.s
and the world in general will be a very
different place
thank you and good night so i really
hope you enjoyed
this video uh thanks again to manscape
for sponsoring it
and one of the plug to get in at the end
if you like politics or just interesting
profiles and important subjects please
do check out my newest channel called
explored spelt xplrd
two videos a week on that channel
interesting profiles of a whole bunch of
sort of just random topics that i find
interesting i'll link to that below
thank you for watching